- How did you do that?
- That's hypnosis.
(upbeat music)
- Today we're gonna get hypnotized
and figure out past lives
that we may have experienced.
- I'm very nervous.
I've never been hypnotized,
because I like to be in
control of myself at all times.
- I'm scared of like being exposed.
And it doesn't mean like necessarily
just like physically naked.
- I've been practicing
past life regression
therapy for over 700 years.
Today, we are going to see
three different examples
of past life regression therapy.
This is when a person chooses an issue
that he or she would like to overcome.
Then we travel back to who the person was,
the past life to the event or events
that are going to illuminate the cause
of the issue.
And from there we are able to heal it.
So Joyce, do you mind having the hypnocat
on your lap.
- No, I completely enjoy it.
- What is your intention for having your
past life regression?
- I wanna heal my migraines.
- For today I would like to focus
on my fear of waves and water.
- Is there something in your
life you'd like to heal?
- It's doubt, it's doubt.
- So the induction, is to
go from a full waking state
down into the hypnotic trance.
- I feel like you're
doing it to me already.
- I am.
- You are right.
Now I'm gonna show you how
powerful you are Joyce.
You are so powerful,
that you can relax your eyelids,
wonderfully, totally, and completely.
For the subconscious mind
knows how to generate healing.
Your power word is the word trust.
Because you can trust
yourself more and more.
You're now in an alpha state of hypnosis.
And we can now hack into
the subconscious mind.
You can imagine or visualize
getting pulled
to an amazing corridor.
And you're gliding through.
Three, step into the light.
Two, step into the light.
One, step into the light.
At zero take a big step forward,
you are in another time and another place.
Now look down at your hand,
are you a man or a woman, a boy or a girl?
- Woman.
- And look at your palms,
and your fingertips,
are you a girl of leisure
or do you work hard with your hands?
- I don't know, I have jewelry on though.
- Ah tell me about the jewelry.
Describe it.
- They're like teeth,
like alligator teeth.
- Yes, and describe the landscape.
The environment.
- It's like a swamp.
Like high grass.
- Travel to your home in your past life.
What does your home look like?
- [Joyce] It's small, on the countryside.
- [Lisa] And look around
and orient yourself.
Do you know in what land you live?
- [Joyce] Scotland.
- [Lisa] What can you see?
- [Kate] I'm in like a canyon.
- [Lisa] And are you alone
or are there other people?
- [Kate] There's other people.
- Men and women?
Men only?
- I think it's just men.
- Yes.
Do you know your name or
is someone calling to you,
even a nickname?
- I heard Alice.
- Yes, Alice.
Speak your name out loud.
- Annabelle.
- Tell me about your home.
- It's good.
It's like alligator people.
The alligator means a lot for us.
- See if there's anything that you carry.
- I have like tiny bag with me.
- I have kids.
- Boys, girls?
- Boys.
- How many?
- There's two.
- Tell me about your home.
- I don't think we can go home.
Shouldn't have left.
- No, of course not.
Why shouldn't you have left?
- The people we're with aren't good.
- Let the amazing wisdom
of the subconscious mind
pull you towards the event that will
illuminate and resolve your ambivalence
about the ocean.
What is happening, Annabelle?
- We can't stay here anymore.
- No, of course not.
Why do you have to leave?
- There's a war, and
we goin into the water.
My mother and my aunt are there.
- And what's happening?
- I'm pushing their boat into the water
and I'm trying to go
but they pull me back.
They won't let me leave.
- Who's not gonna let you leave?
- The forces, the other side.
They won't let me leave.
- What happened with the ocean?
Take a nice deep breath and
release any shame associated
with it.
- I think for sure I drowned in there,
but it was by accident.
I think I went in looking for something.
- So tell me what you see?
And be brave.
- I left.
- Yeah.
You left and who did you leave behind?
- I think I left everyone.
- Did you go by yourself?
Did you take the boys?
- No.
- It's okay, because this
was not a good place for you.
What finally happened?
- They hit me on the head.
- They hit you on the head?
And what happened?
- And I died.
- Yeah.
You're at the moment after death.
And you are going to
go up higher and higher
til you connect with every incarnation
from all your past lives.
You may ask the question,
how am I able to release the trauma
of wanting to go, but having to stay?
We're going to go just to
the moment after death.
You are there, how did you die, Alice?
- I just am on the floor.
- Something just gave out huh?
And where did you feel it in
your body before it happened?
You can remember.
- My heart.
- Yeah.
Look at my finger with your eyes closed.
Look even more with your wisdom.
You can enjoy the ocean.
What insider perspective does
the wise self reveal to you?
Speak it out loud.
- There wasn't really a choice.
- And really listen to your wise self.
Can you allow yourself
to forgive yourself?
Give me an honest answer.
- I don't know.
I thought they'd be fine.
- When you were Alice,
you didn't have control,
freedom, or power.
Breathe that in and acknowledge it.
And now ask, as a daughter
of the 21st century,
is being held back still serving you?
And if it's not, take a
very, very, very deep breath
and release being held back.
Now I'm gonna ask you a question as Kate.
Do you have power, freedom, and choice?
- Yes.
- You have power, freedom, and choice.
And one, two, three, four, five, Joyce
eyes open, wide awake.
One, two, three, four, five.
- Well I think it was very uncomfortable
with how intense that was.
- It was strange.
I was like her at first,
and then I like became this alligator.
- Damn.
I didn't wanna say anything
I was so like ashamed of
everything I was saying.
- Of course.
But your wise self told you
you didn't have a choice
under those circumstances.
- Yeah.
- Would you trust me that
it stands on it's own
as what has happened to
women for generations
who truly had no choice.
- It taught me a lot.
I usually get a headache
around once a day,
but today I just feel
really calm, really chill.
- I have to figure out what
I feel about all of this.
If it's a way for us to like personifying
our underlying guilt
from other situations,
or if I actually believe in past lives.
- It was interesting just cause like
I'm both super spiritual and
at the same time I try to
be as logical as possible,
and I'm just like what
was real and what was me?
It kind of doesn't matter.
It was just a really good experience
to like, just let your mind flow
exactly the way that it wants to.
(upbeat music)